The minute you leave the comfort of your own home,...
...masking is the new normal.
But, it's also becoming a major fashion statement with celebrities like Lady Gaga, J.Lo and Lizzo,...
...who are masking up in everything from glitter to spikes.
But, are these fashionable masks effective against COVID-19?
I picked up a number of masks from street vendors and online retailers...
...and I'm going to test them using a couple of methods...
...scientists use to gauge mask efficiency.
If I can blow out this candle with the mask on, it's leaking too much air.
If this water seeps through the mask, it's leaking too much fluid.
Let's use this blue surgical mask at baseline.
As you can see, it doesn't touch the flame at all.
Water doesn't go through it at all either.
This blue sparkly nylon number passes both tests, and we're off to a great start.
This floral cotton mask, it's pretty thin.,...
...but it passes the candle test and fails the water one.
This pretty in pink lacy one barely passes the flame test,...
...but definitely doesn't pass the water test.
This pretty butterfly nylon polyester blend mask passes the candle test very well,...
...but not so much the water one.
This rainbow mask has a waterproof material on the outside...
...and passes both tests with flying colors.
This leopard gaiter is super thin nylon and barely passes the candle test.
It definitely fails the water one.
This fleece gaiter is pretty thick and passes the flame test.
But once again, not the water one.
So, knowing these findings, should we be picking function over fashion...
...when it comes to choosing a mask?